[Música]
el ejército de Sudán acepta un alto el
fuego de tres días en los combates
contra el grupo paramilitar fuerzas de
apoyo rápido combates que han causado la
muerte de más de 400 personas en siete
días de enfrentamientos ya han fracasado
tres acuerdos de cese de hostilidades
el gobierno de los talibanes en
Afganistán ha despojado a las mujeres de
sus derechos el régimen las Ha privado
de acceso a la educación Universitaria
lo que sumado a la falta de personal
médico femenino pone en riesgo la salud
de millones de afganas
y tras una larga batalla judicial la
expresidente peruano Alejandro Toledo se
entregó a la justicia de Estados Unidos
para ser extraditado a Perú donde está
acusado de corrupción en el marco del
caso odebrecht ampliamos desde Lima
Buenas tardes Bienvenidos a las noticias
de France 24 en español Soy Rosa Pérez
masgueu y es para mí un gusto
acompañarles abrimos esta edición
informativa de nuevo en Sudán Por qué
coincidiendo con la festividad musulmana
de la it el ejército regular acordó un
alto el fuego de tres días con el grupo
paramilitar fuerzas de apoyo rápido sin
embargo las fuerzas armadas regulares y
ha denunciaron violaciones de La tregua
por parte de sus rivales por otro lado
en un reciente comunicado las milicias
declaran la reapertura parcial de los
aeropuertos del país para permitir la
evacuación de extranjeros Aunque la
agencia reuters informa que es incierto
Si las fuerzas de apoyo rápido controlan
los aeropuertos de Sudán En todo caso
después del fracaso de las treguas
anteriores el de hoy es el cuarto
acuerdo de cese de hostilidades en 7
días de enfrentamientos por el control
del país
enfrentamientos que Según la OMS han
causado la muerte de más de 400 personas
y han herido a más de 3.000
en otras noticias palestinos afganos o
sudaneses musulmanes festejan el aid
celebración que pone fin al mes sagrado
del ramadán la festividad llega en medio
de conflictos que causan centenares de
muertos y miles de heridos repasemos
algunos testimonios en gaza kabul y
jartum sobre lo que significa el fin del
ramadán el informe es de Samuel Salgado
el mes del ayuno la oración y la
reflexión en comunidad para el islam
culmina contenciones políticas en varios
países musulmanes
Durante este ramadán la violencia llegó
hasta el interior de la mezquita de
alaxa en Jerusalén el tercer lugar más
sagrado para los seguidores de Mahoma la
policía israelí atacó a decenas de
fieles y arrestó a centenares otros en
medio de una redada antiterrorista según
autoridades de Israel tras una escalada
de las tensiones con los territorios
palestinos hoy en medio de la
celebraciones del atem portavoz de jamás
grupo islamista que controla la franja
de gaza recuerda las tensiones entre
musulmanes y judíos
se celebra este año después de una
batalla librada por nuestro pueblo
palestino tras la agresión contra la
mezquita de alaxa y una guerra religiosa
total
a más de 3000 kilómetros en la capital
de Afganistán la deplorable situación de
derechos de las mujeres y la crisis
humanitaria tras la retoma talibán en
agosto 2021 afecta a los festejos de
Late
es muy diferente a los anteriores antes
nuestros amigos estaban aquí y vamos a
sus casas y lucíamos nuestra ropa éramos
tan felices pero ahora ellos se fueron
del país y nosotras no podemos ir a
ningún lado
mientras que en África los combates
entre el ejército sudanés y el grupo
paramilitar fuerzas de apoyo rápido No
cesan en las calles de jartum ignorando
los múltiples llamados a tregua por la
celebración de Late
llega este año mientras nuestro país se
des angra con muertos y heridos saludo a
los soldados de mi país ustedes se
sacrifican por esta querida patria
Según la OMS el ramadán cierra con más
de 400 muertos en Sudán
vamos ahora de Reino Unido porque cayó
un nuevo miembro del gobierno el
ministro de justicia y Vice Primer
Ministro dominicrap presentó su renuncia
el desencadenante ha sido un informe que
confirma que rap acoso laboralmente a
compañeros de trabajo a su paso por
diferentes carteras gubernamentales
entre los años 2018 y 2022 el informe
fue encargado por el Primer Ministro
Richie sunak muy cercano a dominicrap
quien se defendió en una entrevista con
la bbc
mira inadvertidamente quiero decir Alan
toli sugirió que había sido abrasivo sin
querer Mira si alguien hirió sus
sentimientos por algo que hice Por
supuesto Quiero un equipo empoderado la
gran mayoría de los funcionarios que
trabajaron para mí son brillantes
fantásticos y realmente disfrutaron de
la energía El desafío y el impulso que
creo que traje Pero por supuesto No
quiero molestar a nadie y dejen Claro
que lo siento por eso pero eso no es
intimidación y no podemos cumplir con
británicos y el listón es tan bajo
en otras noticias reunidos en Rammstein
base aérea de Estados Unidos en Alemania
los aliados de Ucrania discutieron el
envío de nuevo armamento ante la
insistente petición de follodimirse
lensky de más apoyo para lanzar la
anunciada contraofensiva de primavera
los aliados están divididos en torno a
la demanda ucraniana de aviones de
combate occidentales y esta semana
confirmó la recepción de sistemas
antiaéreos Patriot después de recibir
desde marzo tanques leopard armamento
que recordemos también creó divisiones
entre los aliados occidentales en su
momento y que hoy ha hecho objeto de uno
de los acuerdos alcanzados Alemania
Polonia y Ucrania establecerán un centro
de mantenimiento de leopard en
territorio polanés
Afuera
estoy muy contento de haber podido
firmar un memorando de entendimiento hoy
con mi colega polaco y mi colega
ucraniano o Lexi sobre el hecho de que
estableceremos un personal de
mantenimiento conjunto en Polonia para
toda la flota Leo 2 es decir el 2 a 4 y
el 2 a 6 de modo que cerca de la
frontera entre Polonia y Ucrania se
garantice que estos tanques se puedan
mantener y reparar rápidamente a medida
que aumente la necesidad
en otros temas en Afganistán la salud de
las mujeres está en grave peligro Y es
que las facultades de Medicina se quedan
sin alumnas ya que la educación superior
está prohibida a las mujeres por otro
lado los hospitales también se quedan
sin médicas además por falta de un
hombre que las acompañe como exige el
régimen talibán las pacientes viudas sin
hijos o sin parientes varones no pueden
desplazarse solas a los centros de salud
este hospital recibe cada día a más de
500 pacientes de toda la provincia de
paruán en el ala femenina hay cientos de
mujeres esperando los varones que las
acompañan desde un largo trayecto como
exige el régimen talibán aguardan a un
lado
me duelen mucho los riñones he venido
aquí con uno de mis hijos y mi madre que
tiene problemas oculares no tenemos
dinero tuve que suplicar a un taxista
que nos trajera y pagamos 20 afganis por
cada persona para sentarnos en el
maletero llegamos aquí y ni siquiera
tienen analgésicos estoy sufriendo mucho
y no sé qué hacer
ninguna mujer afgana estudia medicina a
las niñas se les niega la educación
secundaria y superior en este
departamento de ginecología escaso de
personal se teme lo peor para el futuro
Sí pero muy poca
[Música]
también le duele el abdomen
Sí es bastante fuerte
en el servicio de ginecología solo
tenemos una jefa médica el futuro parece
sombrío los hombres nunca dejarán que
las mujeres vean a médicos hombres cada
vez más mujeres tendrán que dar a luz en
casa sin asistencia médica Incluso hoy
los hombres tienen dificultades para
llevar a sus esposas al hospital la tasa
de mortalidad materna será mayor
Afganistán ya tiene una de las tasas de
mortalidad materna más altas del mundo
con 638 muertes por cada 100.000
nacimientos las antiguas estudiantes de
Medicina como Leyla están desesperadas
antes quería ser médico para ayudar a mi
pueblo ahora no sé qué hacer
no sé qué quieren hacer los talibanes
con nosotros
no sabemos si tienen algún plan para las
niñas y las mujeres
privadas de Educación excluidas del
mundo laboral salvo algunas excepciones
obligadas a ir acompañadas de un varón
cuando viajan las mujeres son más
vulnerables que nunca en Afganistán
y tras años de batalla legal en
California finalmente el expresidente
peruano Alejandro Toledo se entregó a la
justicia de Estados Unidos para ser
extraditado a Perú donde enfrenta cargos
por corrupción particularmente esta
acusado de recibir millonarios sobornos
a cambio de licitar obra pública a la
empresa odebrecht durante sus años de
presidente Es decir desde 2001 a 2006
desde Lima nuestro corresponsal
Francisco Zacarías nos ampliaba
previamente lo que sigue a continuación
es que agentes de la agencia de
cooperación internacional junto con
efectivos de la Interpol así como
personal de cancillería peruana va a
acudir a California Estados Unidos para
iniciar los trámites de extradición Esto
fue anunciado previamente por el
ministro de Justicia peruano José Tello
horas antes de su entrega a los agentes
federales en Estados Unidos Alejandro
Toledo le exigió a las autoridades
comunidades peruanas que le otorguen el
mismo trato que le están brindando al
expresidente Pedro Pablo kuczynski es
decir no una prisión sino un arresto
domiciliario Toledo ha sido muy enfático
al señalar que no solamente se debe de
investigar a su gobierno sino a los
gobiernos que
transcurrieron antes de su gestión
existen mucha expectativa por lo que
Alejandro Toledo le pueda contar a las
autoridades peruanas quizás a estas
horas que ya está bajo custodia Federal
tratar de Iniciar una negociación con la
fiscalía peruana para tratarle delatar a
Cómplices brindar información a fin de
que pueda obtener algunos beneficios de
pena de condena Toledo como se recuerda
está investigado por la fiscalía peruana
ya se ha iniciado un juicio en este país
y la fiscalía lo acusa de recibir
sobornos de la empresa constructora
brasile odebrecht por 35 millones de
dólares para la construcción de la
carretera interoceánica que fue uno de
los principales orgullos del gobierno de
Alejandro Toledo al tratar de unir Perú
con Brasil a través de esta carretera
continuamos con más noticias de América
Latina porque el presidente de Argentina
anunció que no se va a presentar a la
reelección en los comicios
presidenciales de este octubre Alberto
Fernández comunicó su decisión a través
de un vídeo publicado en su cuenta de
Twitter en el que también apoyó la
celebración de primarias dentro del
frente de todos para elegir al candidato
de la izquierda recordemos que la actual
vicepresidenta Cristina Fernández de
kirchner también rechazó presentarse a
las elecciones después de ser condenada
por corrupción un proceso que está en
fase de apelación y que la mandataria
calificó de decisión de la mafia
judicial desde Buenos Aires a nuestro
corresponsal natalio cosoy nos Explica
qué candidatos del podrían liderar la
coalición peronista del frente de todos
él es igual a presidencia no como un
candidato que se había lanzado solo por
cuenta propia por su deseo personal sino
por decisión de la vicepresidenta
Cristina Fernández de kirchner
expresidenta de la nación ella fue la
que anunció la candidatura de él como
presidente y ella como Vice Y muchos
dicen aquí que la idea de una posible
reelección de Alberto Fernández de una
candidatura de reelección de Alberto
Fernández siempre fue algo poco claro él
nunca lo había dicho explícitamente
Ahora no dijo explícitamente que
renunciado en el video de casi 8 minutos
en el que difundió esta decisión sino
que habló de que le tras la le
traspasará la banda presidencial cuando
sea decidido Quién es el próximo
presidente de Argentina el 10 de
diciembre próximo sobre los candidatos
es muy difícil está débil la coalición
en algún punto tras varios años de ser
gobierno y eso además es el gobierno del
medio de la pandemia y con las
dificultades económicas que atraviesa el
país y hay algunos nombres en danza
ninguno definitivo algunos hablan del
ministro de economía Sergio massa él
Hasta ahora ha dicho que no que no está
pensando en eso otros dentro de la
coalición hablan del gobernador de la
provincia de Buenos Aires Axel kicillof
Pero él dice que prefiere ir hasta donde
sabemos a una reelección como gobernador
hay otros nombres en danza también guado
de Pedro Eduardo guadado Pedro que es
ministro del interior algunos están
hablando Agustín Rossi que es jefe de
gabinete Les estoy dando varios nombres
Daniel scioli también que es el actual
embajador en Brasil hay falta de
definición realmente ese es el problema
que por ahí tiene ahora se puede decir
el frente de todos
y la UNESCO incluyó el texto arte
vocabulario y catecismo en lengua moxa
en el registro de la memoria del mundo
por su importancia histórica y
documental el libro preservado en La Paz
es un trabajo realizado en
1701 por el jesuita español Pedro marbán
que registró por ejemplo las más de 200
formas que la comunidad moxa tiene para
referirse al agua el moxo es un idioma
en peligro de desaparición propio de
comunidades del noreste boliviano y es
una de las 26 lenguas reconocidas por la
constitución del Estado plurinacional de
Bolivia
llegamos así al final de esta emisión
pero sigan con nosotros y más
información
[Música]